my name is Karen I'll be taking care of
you are you connected apartment yes I am
I'm TJ and uncle Chris's nice okay nice
and just in a nutshell what's wrong my
place now there's no communication
between my aunt and uncle it's gotten a
million times worse since my grandfather
passed away
yeah I asked mother to come here because
my family desperately needs his help
they've been struggling for way too long
they don't know what to do we really
need us help this is the dinner menu Wow
what would you say cupcakes the crab
cakes yeah their hitter messed up the
hill with cupcakes what else I'll take
some calamari okay
Jonas a little toasted lager how do you
like it cooked medium rare medium rare
all right listen this is Ramsey crab
cakes
calamari with gorgonzola when he wants
the burger medium rare I am very proud
of my food whenever I eat other places I
think we're better than 90% of them we
have Palmer in the liner off the crab
cakes let's do this together too much
please come on justperson mind my
wingman
I had to swallow it was not enjoyable
heiio miss for me that's a miss yes holy
[ __ ] how was lunch my darling it wasn't
very good and everything feels
institutional rice you know like we just
got out of the hospital that's the best
food again I'm sorry it's not a nice
surprise on Mother's Day hey cocktail
sauce pork in lemon monkey this for the
marinara fried calamari
can you hear any crispy juicy pants
limper than my granddad's dick oh my god
oh my god oh my god the calamari was
mostly greasy you know I have to bring
this food out you know he's gonna
critique it and you know I'm gonna come
right back within one second because you
don't care you're just setting me like
[ __ ] on a plate basically are these the
Marshalls Mike
my bad guy thank you very much
Jesus where's my bag oh what a mess
did you tell him is medium rare Jesus
it's wrong does not lead to rare what a
shame that is dreadful
my uncle can't cook a burger medium-rare
and freaking kidding me
okay tell me three nice Jesus yeah thank
you all your uncle yeah I'm cool I can't
believe how bad my food was I've got to
see the kitchen in action for myself
right back here is my husband Mike
[Applause]
okay so TJ's new brother yes Mike Kudo
my why's that this is Tran time
fire you have a mushroom wrap one all
day in a Primavera
[Applause]
okay am i okay yeah repleted ten minutes
I'm amazed none of you can ask me how
our lunch was what's most shocking isn't
the food or that they have zero interest
in my experience as a diner it's the
fact that Chris and his sister don't
exchange a single word they wouldn't
even look at each other you could cut
the atmosphere in here with a knife wow
this guy must really hate mothers the
way he's treating these dishes you put
food on a plate like you're stopping can
I borrow that top a minute you're wiping
plates through this you don't care
to say that not know me at all doesn't
have any foundation there's anything
come to order here
crater ice salads french fries salad 20
[ __ ] dollars a head for that Chris
doesn't seem like an owner or a chef he
isn't even cooking
he's just heating things up Chris you
got two seconds please here's where I'm
getting frustrated you own the place you
cook like you hate the place come on
Chris talk to me please
if you're not going to talk to me then
I'm wasting my time here